vamos ahora al problema 145 145 en este
problema nos piden determinar si uno
entre p uno entre p es mayor que erre
dividido entre r cuadrada más dos es re
cuadrada más dos antes de empezar a
hacer manipulaciones vamos a ver qué
dicen los incisos vale en el inciso uno
nos dicen que p es igual a r p es igual
a r entonces sustituyendo p igual a r
aquí lo que necesitamos verificar es si
uno entre r le gana a r / r cuadrada más
r cuadrada + 2 bueno pues voy a
multiplicar cruzado pero debo tener
cuidado al multiplicar por ere cuadrada
más 2 no sucede nada con la desigualdad
porque es re cuadrada es positiva y al
sumarle 2 queda algo positivo entonces
ahí no hay problema este mayor sigue
siendo mayor vale pero cuando multiplica
cruzado por esta r voy a tener dos casos
cierre es positivo cierre es mayor que
cero entonces no pasa nada es decir
tendríamos es re cuadrada más 2 mayor
que es re cuadrada sale y esto es
equivalente a que 2 sea mayor que 0
restamos ere cuadrada de ambos lados y
estoy aquí es cierto sin embargo cuando
r es menor que cero cuando eres menor
que cero lo que sucede es que al
multiplicar por r para cancelarlo de
este lado va a cambiar el signo de esta
desigualdad cuando multiplicamos por el
recuerda más 2 no ahí no pasa nada o sea
al lado izquierdo de todas formas nos
queda re cuadrada más 2 pero ahora esta
desigualdad se voltea nos quedaría menor
que
r cuadrada restando erre cuadrada de
ambos lados esto es equivalente
equivalente a que 2 sea menor que cero
lo cual es falso y de esta forma la
información de este inciso no es
suficiente para ver si esta desigualdad
se da o no vale depende del signo de r
bueno vamos ahora el inciso 2 inciso 2
dice que amira r nos dice que r es mayor
que 0 sabe que europea r es mayor que 0
bueno la información del inciso 2 por sí
misma va a ser inútil porque no tienen
nada que ver con p pero juntando la con
la del inciso 1 sabemos que caemos en
este caso y por lo tanto sabemos que la
desigualdad es cierta vale entonces la
respuesta sería c
eso quiere decir que necesitamos ambos
incisos para responder esta pregunta
vamos ahora a las 146 preguntas 146 aquí
simplemente nos preguntan si n es un
entero n es
entero
ok en el inciso 1 lo que nos dice es que
n cuadrada es un entero n cuadrada es un
entero
pero pues esto de aquí no dice gran cosa
verdad que elevemos un número al
cuadrado y nos quede un entero no nos
garantiza que el número original sea
entero por ejemplo por ejemplo si
tomamos raíz de 2 y lo elevamos al
cuadrado entonces esto es igual a 2 pero
eso eso no hace que raíz de dos sea un
entero vale por otro lado si tomamos 3 y
lo elevamos al cuadrado también nos
queda un entero y en este caso si
tenemos que el número original con el
que empezamos era un entero pero como
tenemos ambos casos la información del
inciso 1 no es suficiente vamos a ver el
inciso 2
el inciso 2 dice que raíz cuadrada de n
es un entero es un
entero
entero este de aquí si nos da la
información de que en ese a un entero
verdad si raíz de n es un entero pues
cualquier entero elevado al cuadrado
pues es un entero entonces tendríamos
raíz cuadrada de n al cuadrado es igual
a un entero
entero un entero por sí mismo siempre es
un entero pero a la vez raíz cuadrada de
n al cuadrado es n entonces tendríamos
que n raíz de n al cuadrado que es un
entero por un entero que dejaría entero
entonces la información del inciso 2 si
permite responder la pregunta y así la
respuesta sería b esta fue una pregunta
inusualmente fácil a estas alturas
verdad bueno vamos ahora al problema 147
147 muy bien en el problema 147 nos
dicen que es un entero positivo n es
entero
entero positivo
positivo y lo que tenemos que determinar
es si en el cubo menos n n al cubo menos
n le voy a poner que abro pregunta en el
cubo - n es múltiplo de 4 esto está
padre verdad múltiplo de 4
ok voy a bajar para tener más espacio
quizás aquí si convenga simplificar un
poco esta expresión antes antes de
empezar a leer los incisos lo que yo
haría es factorizar la porque bueno
déjame echarle un ojo a los incisos a
ver el inciso 1 nos dicen que n es igual
a 2 k más uno con cada entero cada
entero entonces creo que si conviene
simplificar la por que elevar esta
expresión al cubo pues va a estar bien
feo entonces déjame factorizar en el
cubo menos n tenemos que n al cubo
- n es igual a igual a n por m cuadrada
menos 1 y n cuadrada menos 1 es una
diferencia de cuadrados que es igual a n
1 por n 1 entonces esta expresión sería
n 1 x n x n + 1
muy bien entonces n 1 x n x n 1 sale
entonces ahora sí vamos a poner la
información del inciso 1 en esta
factoría acción para ver si nos queda un
múltiplo de 4 si ponemos en iguala dos
camas 1 entonces este de aquí sería 4
que no sería 2 k
2k x n x 2 k más 1 x 2 camas 11 o sea
por 2k + 2 y observa que aquí hay un
factor 2 que podemos sacar esto lo
podemos poner como 4
el factor 2 salió y está multiplicando
este 2 lo podemos poner como 4 por acá
por 2 cada uno y al factorizar el 2 nos
queda aquí cada más uno y esto de aquí
ya es un múltiplo de 4 verdad es 4 por
esta expresión de acá y esta expresión
de acá sabemos que es un entero porque
nos dicen que acá es entero entero todo
esto es entero todo esto es entero y por
lo tanto nos queda 4 por un entero de
esta forma de esta forma tenemos que n
al cubo
n es un múltiplo de 4 verdad al
dividirlo entre 4 nos queda esto de acá
que es un entero muy bien entonces la
información del inciso 1 sí fue
suficiente vamos a ver qué nos dice el
inciso 2 el inciso 2 nos dice que n
cuadrada más n
me cuadrada más n
es divisible divisible visible entre
entre 6 ok esto qué quiere decir haber n
cuadrada + n cuadrada + n es lo mismo
que voy a factorizar una n n por n 1
entonces lo que nos están diciendo es
que este pedacito de acá voy a tomar
otro color
esta hipótesis es decir que este
pedacito de acá es múltiplo de 6
múltiplos de 6
de 6 pero creo que eso todavía no nos
dice gran cosa o sea para para acumular
un múltiplo de 4
nos gustaría juntar dos factores 2 pero
si algo es múltiplo de 6 solo tiene un
factor 2 entonces puede ser o puede no
ser que n 1 tenga este factor déjame ver
si puedo encontrar algún ejemplo a ver
qué valores pueden satisfacer que n por
ende más uno sea divisible entre 6
nn igualados verdad tienes igualados
entonces en 1
es 3 y n por n 1 s 6 entonces eso cumple
y esta expresión que sería sería 1 por
dos por tres
entonces en este caso en este caso la
expresión en el cubo menos n n al cubo
- n sería igual a 6 que no es múltiplo
de 4 vale pero qué sucede digamos si n
es igual a 3
tiene es igual a 3 100 es igual a 3
entonces en uno sería igual a 12 sería
igual a 4 perdón n por n uno sería igual
a 12 y eso de ahí es múltiplo de 6 y
esta expresión de la casería dos por
tres por cuatro y esta de acá claramente
es múltiplo de cuatro verdad porque ahí
tiene su 4 entonces ahí está tenemos el
caso en igualados que nos queda que n
cuadrado más en es divisible en 36 pero
pero venía al cubo - n no es múltiplo de
4 y el caso n igual a 3 en el cual en el
cual también tenemos que n cuadrada más
n es múltiplo de 6 es divisible en 36
pero en el cubo menos n si es divisible
entre 4 entonces la información del
inciso 2 nos sirve para determinar si
tiene al cubo menos en es múltiplo de 4
o no y por lo tanto la respuesta a este
ejercicio sería a
muy bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí y en
el siguiente vídeo continuamos con más
problemas